então boa tarde é caros colegas
eu vou falar o objetivo da minha fala é
contar o que é o básico fundamental do
trabalho que os lógicos do centro de
lógica da unicamp desenvolvem aqui na
unicamp é o título que eu coloquei é o
centro de lógica da unicamp as lógicas
não clássicas contemporâneas
bom o que nós podemos considerar que
seja lógica a lógica ea ciência do
raciocínio é considerada a ciência que
estuda a razão é como tal nós temos
contemporaneamente três tipos de lógica
até princípios do século 20 e só se
pensava numa única lógica dedutiva nós
temos a lógica dedutiva que corresponde
a ciência do raciocínio dedutivo nesse
sentido a loja que estuda há a relação
de consequência isto é a lógica estuda
as inferências válidas significa aquelas
referências que a partir de premissas o
hipóteses verdadeiras obtém conclusões
verdadeiras mas nós temos um outro tipo
de lógica que é chamada a lógica
indutiva que é o estudo das referências
prováveis por exemplo 80% dos
entrevistados votaram no candidato x
portanto o candidato x deverá ganhar as
eleições é um tipo de lógica que não me
garante a veracidade da conclusão
não me garante a validade do raciocínio
não é um raciocínio lógico mas é um
raciocínio provável mas
contemporaneamente nós temos estudado e
temos um grupo no centro de lógica que
estuda os trabalhos de tchau spams que o
lógico um químico de profissão americano
talvez o maior pensador americano nos
últimos séculos
ele faleceu aqui desapareceu em 1914
estamos comemorando 100 anos da sua
morte
se é o pai do pragmatismo foi o primeiro
a defender que a verdade não é absoluta
lares tottenham é verdade contextual
depende do contexto e 12 argumentou os
seus trabalhos que o verdadeiro
raciocínio feito
pelos cientistas em especial pelos
cientistas e empíricos é o que ele
chamou de raciocínio do tivo segundo pan
se o cientista o que faz de fato é
abstrair dos fenômenos de da observação
certas hipóteses de trabalho e seria um
raciocínio dedutivo ao contrário ele
assumisse hipóteses assumir essas
hipóteses como básicas para o
desenvolvimento de suas teorias dos seus
sistemas raciocínio dedutivo somente a
partir dessas hipóteses até que as
coisas funcionam
a teoria e observar viu a teoria e
olímpico a teoria ea experiência
se alguma coisa acontece no próprio de
problema
se algo não bate com a observação do
fenômeno na realidade o que diz o percy
o cientista para ele vai ver primeiro se
ele errou na teoria na dedução
depois ele vai ver se ele ronaldo
servação quando ele observa verifica que
ele não é ruim nada ele disse poxa o que
está errado ea minha hipótese ele revê a
hipótese é isso que se chama raciocínio
dedutivo começa de novo a desenvolver a
teoria e prata se esse é o verdadeiro
raciocínio do cientista mas até
princípio do século 20
havia uma única lógica pura formal
teórica ou dedutiva que foi fundada por
aristóteles que é considerado o pai da
lógica filósofo grego no século 4º antes
de cristo
para aristóteles a lógica é a ciência do
raciocínio dedutivo é a ciência que
estuda e analisa os raciocínios válido
significa que eles que a partir de
hipóteses ou premissas verdadeiras só
pode chegar a conclusões verdadeiras mas
para aristóteles existem é ele afirmou
nos na sua obra nos primeiros analíticos
que para o raciocínio a três leis
básicas que são chamadas hoje leis
básicas do pensamento aristotélico
aristóteles afirmou e e procurou
argumentar categoricamente que a
primeira lei mais básica para o
raciocínio dedutivo é chamado princípio
da não contradição aqui formalmente na
nossa linguagem contemporânea significa
nunca pode ser o caso de aí não é não
pode haver contradição
não pode uma sentença
negação ser verdadeiras ao mesmo tempo
segundo o princípio básico do terceiro
excluído não há uma terceira
possibilidade dado a qualquer tem que
avaliar ou não é
e a terceira lei básica aristotélica é
conhecida como reflexividade de
identidade ela diz qualquer que seja xx
guaches bom essas leis elas foram
consideradas indiscutíveis até princípio
do século 20 e elas tiveram por base no
raciocínio filosófico lógico matemático
e da ciência como um todo
nas primeiras décadas do século 20
vários lógicos filósofos e matemáticos
criaram novos sistemas lógicos distintos
da lógica aristotélica isso portanto
vinte e quatro séculos depois de
aristóteles essas lógicas baseadas em
linguagens artificiais em linguagens que
são explicitados antes do
desenvolvimento de teoria elas têm
servido como lógica sistemas básicos
para diversas áreas da ciência elas são
conhecidas como lógicas dão clássicas
entre as lógicas não clássicas nós temos
três categorias muito importante de
lógicas as que são chamadas lógicas para
consistentes as que são chamadas lógicas
para completas e as que são chamadas
lojas dão reflexivas voltando opção
essas lógicas as lógicas não reflexivas
são aquelas lógicas em que o princípio
básico de aristóteles refletividade da
identidade não é válida em geral são
lógicas em que um x pode ser extinto de
si mesmo
quem sabe física sabe hoje que a lógica
subjacente a mecânica quântica não
reflexiva o tesouro ot o outro segundo
tipo de lógica de trás para diante as
lógicas para completas são aquelas em
que o princípio do terceiro excluído não
é válido em geral são lógicas em que nós
podemos ter a ser sonhos afirmações a
tais que não valha o ar e também não
falha ou não a exemplo de lógica desse
tipo lógicas polivalentes lógicas
impressionistas e as lógicas chan que
mais chocam na história da lógica
são as chamadas lógicas para
consistentes são lógicas nas quais em
que o princípio do técnico básico da não
contratação pode não ser válido em geral
o grande problema da não contratação em
ciência ou da contradição é que de uma
contradição
nós podemos deduzir qualquer coisa o
sistema em que a contradição vira
trivial nas lógicas para consistentes o
que acontece
nós podemos lidar com fórmulas a e não
há a sua negação e esta lei que acontece
na lógica clássica de hainan eu tiro b
qualquer não é válida em geral estão nas
lojas para consistente nós podemos lidar
com inconsistências com contradições
sempre realização das teorias fundadas
nas lógicas é nilton da costa um dos
fundadores do centro de lógica da
unicamp meu orientador de doutorado é
considerado o verdadeiro fundador da
lógica paraconsistente quebrando um
paradigma de vinte e quatro séculos da
história da filosofia e da lógica da
matemática e da ciência muito bem o que
nós fazemos no centro de lógica
fundamentalmente é o estudo de sistemas
lógicos não clássicos em geral em
particular de lógicas para consistentes
então nós trabalhamos com a construção
de sistemas em que há o aparecimento de
informação contraditória o aparecimento
de contradição não invalida o raciocínio
que o sistema me permite desenvolver o
desenvolvimento das lógicas não
clássicas em geral têm aberto várias
áreas de pesquisa e propiciado a solução
de importantes questões do fundamento da
ciência e diversas aplicações inclusive
tecnológicas
contemporaneamente nós temos aeroportos
no mundo em que o sistema de controle de
vôo e é baseado no fundado em lógicas
para consistentes nós temos robôs que
nós temos criados que funcionam com base
na lógica paraconsistente bom pra
terminar
então o que nós nos dedicamos além de
outras áreas
a inter relação de sistemas lógicos dão
clássicos com o clássico
fundamentalmente sistemas não clássicos
de lógica que nos permitem os mais
variados tipos de raciocínio é e
é que nos permitem perceber que a razão
única não é uma não é única
a razão se faz na historicidade com o
desenvolvimento cultural existe não
existe uma lógica melhor que outra mais
uma mais adequada que outra para
determinadas áreas do conhecimento e com
base nisso eu costumo pensar
contemporaneamente que a lógica é a mais
bela e fundamental das disciplinas e que
elas nos privilegia o conhecimento
interior e talvez nos possa garantir a
liberdade do espírito na busca da
verdade através da beleza e do bem e
talvez ela nos abra as portas para o
retorno paraíso pelo conhecimento da
verdade
muito obrigado